hey guys how's it going today we are
heading off to the desert for what I am
calling a tech retreat and yes of course
the dogs coming with us not calling this
a tech retreat because I'm basically
packing up all of my drones some of my
cameras and we're going to the desert to
update firmware I know it's completely
absurd Jenna we're going for a day I've
got five drones in this backpack
smartphone two phones one of these
phones has some beta software for
something secret on it one day to knife
I have a knife too oh yes that's one of
my favorites actually
I have mini knife just as all the other
not and you coming - oh my gosh does he
look handsome
shaggy another wine yes should we bring
a rider away I really have two White's
left this one asabi unblocked yes please
dad's driving it's thank you why are you
this is dirty Wow
Starbucks now has a blonde espresso
roast which I am obsessed with of course
I would say that I'm obsessed because
that's what a basic girl does thanks for
driving because I drove to Vegas for CES
and that was a lot of driving not sure
if I had had a good time hood they
weren't here to witness what happened on
the way home oh wow there's a setting in
my car when you're doing cruise control
it has Lane Assist it'll kind of
basically drive for you not like the
Tesla will but it will do like small
turns and stuff like that but one of the
things is it will detect if it thinks
that you're falling asleep and I'm such
a bad driver that I wasn't falling
asleep but he thought that I was that
would kept yelling at me blinking it
says I have to take a break take a break
four and a half hours of that let's
start up the rx0 I talked about this
thing so many times
[Music]
we've got about an hour left enough we
have to be the bathroom really really
really really bad because Jenna drank
all that straight
we've only been driving for about an
hour and we've already made it to two
stops at Starbucks we had to go to the
bathroom help subsided get some pumpkin
bread where's Jenna
oh this is a problem she's not here look
at us focus I found 10 focus incredible
hey buck he just ran out the door like
ran out I can open to get a shot and you
even so fast we've got a nice little
living room
Jenna's room bathroom my room kitchen
and a nice little fenced-in yard for
Matty to play so I got some shampoo and
conditioner on Amazon Prime I thought it
was travel because it had these little
pumps but those little pumps on top must
have meant that it is basically an
entire gallon 33.8 fluid ounces for two
days breakfast is being made good
morning from Joshua Tree we're making
breakfast all of those plans that we had
to fly drones and update drones
basically you know this tech retreat has
turned into a relaxing retreat and we're
going to go hiking we're basically not
gonna do any of the things that we plan
on doing hey Siri play me some music
let's kick things off with please don't
go by Mike Posner
[Music]
okay two waters there are snacks got our
camera I was excited because I was like
we're gonna be a little nowhere there
will be power lines right by the house
so I can just go outside test her own
there's a power line right over top of
the house so I don't want to fly that
close so really we're just gonna go on a
hike and enjoy the rest of Joshua
together
that's the airflow okay Wow so while
we're driving here we just saw on
Twitter that I was nominated for a
vlogger of the year which is so crazy
because in this past year I actually
stopped vlogging
[Music]
I have been vlogging for a very very
long time and the past year I decided
that I was gonna kind of stop blogging I
cut back I still do vlogs I'm vlogging
right now but for the most part I
focused a lot more on tech a lot more
cooking videos and then in between I
would fill in with vlogging it's kind of
ironic that I basically quit doing the
thing that I was really known for and my
channel became way more successful than
it had in the previous years and now I'm
nominated for a vlogging award I'll take
it that's pretty awesome you guys want
to vote I'll put a link in the
description Rio's can check it out
that's probably the last time that I'm
gonna say to vote because I hate
spamming you guys to vote for things so
with that being said I'm probably not
gonna win but look at me I'm vlogging
[Music]
I've only got point three to our journey
to the 49 Oasis palms Jenna's doing the
voiceover for planet Earth hit her up we
haven't gone very far at all
[Applause]
[Music]
ah-hoo
oh I got pinched by it something amazing
happened there
[Music]
so the odd red corner des rois hair we
are one point two eight miles in it's
taken us sixty two minutes we're almost
the palm-trees it's called forty seven
palms going back is gonna suck cause
this is all uphill mine's not loading
Owen tribal HQ trivia in the middle of
nowhere mine's not working man maybe if
we get to the palms faster we'll have
reception I don't know I see Scott up
one way okay I give up
[Music]
we return
Wow
[Music]
Oh
Wow
you're heading back we've got about two
miles back
it took us almost an hour to get it over
here maybe a little more I'm gonna put
my camera away because it's heavy on the
way back into the put my cots yeah
come here come here yes see ya Mike Wow
well that does it for my tech retreat I
did absolutely nothing that I had
planned on doing I was gonna update all
the firmware on all of my cameras all
the firmware on all of my drones and
guess what I didn't do
I had nothing I drank wine I painted I
watched arrow eat a bunch of
butterfingers we went on a hike
basically everything we do in LA yeah
but I had a really great time this house
is incredible
maddie was a good boy and this looks
really dark for some reason but oh well
hold like this is something's not right
oh well
[Music]